Je suis restée enfermée toute une semaine.
Puis c'était vendredi, cette semaine-là,
le jour où les musulmans se regroupent pour la prière hebdomadaire.
Et de nouveau, les avertissements étaient « N'allez pas à la prière ce vendredi,
elle pourrait être ciblée. »
Je regardais les actualités, une couverture en continu.
Naturellement, les émotions étaient à fleur de peau.
J'entendais également parler de représailles contre les musulmans
ou des gens perçus comme musulmans, jetés dehors
et battus dans la rue.
Des mosquées ont été incendiées.
Et je pensais juste à rester à la maison.
Pourtant, quelque chose n'allait pas.
Car ces personnes qui ont attaqué notre pays,
ont attaqué notre pays à tous.
Je comprends la colère des gens envers les terroristes.
Mais devinez quoi ? Moi aussi j'étais en colère.
Et vous justifier tout le temps n'est pas une mince affaire.
Les questions ne me gênent pas, j'aime les questions.
Ce sont les accusations qui sont dures.
Aujourd'hui, nous entendons les gens dire :
« Il y a un problème dans ce pays, ce sont les musulmans.
Quand allons-nous nous débarrasser d'eux ? »
Des gens veulent bannir les musulmans et fermer les mosquées.
Ils parlent de ma communauté comme s'il s'agissait d'une tumeur
dans le corps américain.
Et la question est : sommes-nous malins ou bénins ?
Vous savez, une tumeur maligne vous devez l'extraire en entier,
alors qu'une tumeur bénigne, vous devez juste la surveiller.
Ce choix n'a aucun sens, car la question n'est pas la bonne.
Les musulmans, comme tout les Américains, ne sont pas une tumeur dans la société.
Nous sommes un organe vital.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Les musulmans sont des inventeurs et des enseignants,
des secouristes et des athlètes olympiques.
Est-ce que l'Amérique sera plus sûre en fermant les mosquées ?
Ça pourrait libérer quelques places de parking,
mais cela n'arrêtera pas le terrorisme,
En fait, aller régulièrement à la mosquée est lié
au fait d'avoir une opinion plus tolérante des personnes d'autres croyances
et d'avoir un grand engagement civique.
Et comme un chef de police dans la région de Washington
m'a dernièrement dit,
en fait, les gens ne se radicalisent pas dans les mosquées
mais plutôt dans leur sous-sol, leur chambre, devant leur ordinateur.
Ce que nous avons appris sur le processus de radicalisation,
c'est qu'il commence en ligne,
mais la première chose qui arrive,
c'est que ces personnes coupent les liens avec leur communauté
et même avec leur famille,
pour que les groupes extrémistes puissent les endoctriner
à croire que les terroristes sont les vrais musulmans
et que tous ceux qui contestent leurs agissements et leur idéologie
sont des traîtres ou des apostats.
Donc, si nous voulons éviter la radicalisation,
nous devons encourager les gens à aller à la mosquée.
Certains vont encore faire valoir que l'islam est une religion violente.
Après tout, un groupe comme Daech appuie sa brutalité sur le Coran.
Et en tant que musulmane, que mère et être humain,
je crois que nous devons tout faire pour mettre fin à un groupe comme Daech.
Mais ce serait céder à leur discours
si nous les prenions comme représentants d'une foi de 1,6 milliard de personnes.
(Applaudissements)
Merci
Daech a autant à voir avec l'islam
que le Ku Klux Klan a à voir avec la chrétienté.
(Applaudissements)
Les deux groupes prétendent fonder leur idéologie sur leur livre sacré.
Mais en les regardant de près, ils ne sont pas motivés
par ce qu'ils lisent dans leur livre sacré.
C'est leur brutalité qui les font lire ces choses dans les saintes écritures.
Récemment, un éminent imam m'a raconté une histoire qui m'a vraiment étonnée.
Il a dit qu'une fille est venue à lui
parce qu'elle pensait rejoindre Daech.
J'étais très surprise et je lui ai demandé :
« Est-ce qu'elle a été en contact avec un chef de groupe radical ? »
Il m'a dit que le problème était le contraire,
que tous les clercs à qui elle avait parlé l'avaient fait taire
et lui avaient dit que sa rage, son sentiment d'injustice dans le monde,
lui causeraient des problèmes.
Et si elle ne canalisait pas ou ne donnait pas de sens à sa colère,
elle serait une cible de choix à exploiter
par des extrémistes qui prétendraient être la solution.
En fait, cet imam l'a reconnectée avec Dieu et sa communauté.
Il ne l'a pas couverte de honte -- il lui a proposé des moyens constructifs
pour faire un vrai changement dans le monde.
Ce qu'elle a appris dans cette mosquée l'a empêchée de rejoindre Daech.
Je vous ai raconté un peu
comment l'islamophobie m'affecte ma famille et moi.
Mais comment affecte-elle les Américains ordinaires ?
Comment impacte-t-elle tout le monde ?
En quoi constamment consommer de la peur affecte-t-il notre démocratie,
notre libre pensée ?
Eh bien, une étude -- en fait, plusieurs études en neurosciences --
montrent que lorsque nous avons peur, au moins trois choses arrivent.
On devient plus tolérant à l'autoritarisme,
à la conformité et aux préjugés.
Une étude a montré que lorsque des sujets ont été exposés à des actualités
qui étaient négatives sur les musulmans,
ils deviennent plus tolérants aux attaques militaires contre les pays musulmans
et aux politiques réduisant les droits des musulmans américains.
Ce n'est pas qu'une question académique.
Lorsque vous regardez quand le sentiment antimusulman a émergé
entre 2001 et 2013,
c'est arrivé trois fois
et ce n'était pas pour des attaques terroristes.
C'était avant la guerre contre l'Irak et durant deux cycles électoraux.
Donc, l'islamophobie n'est pas qu'une réponse naturelle
au terrorisme musulman,
comme je le pensais.
En fait, elle peut être un outil de manipulation publique,
érodant ainsi le fondement même d'une société libre,
dont les citoyens sont rationnels et bien informés.
Les musulmans sont comme des canaris dans une mine de charbon.
On le sentira peut être en premier,
mais l'air toxique de la peur est préjudiciable à nous tous.
(Applaudissements)
Faire une condamnation collective,
ce n'est pas l'obligation de vous expliquer tout le temps.
Deah et son épouse Yusor étaient un jeune couple marié
vivant à Chapel Hill, en Caroline du Nord,
où ils étudiaient tous les deux.
Deah était un athlète.
Il était étudiant dans une école dentaire, talentueux et prometteur...
Sa sœur m'a dit qu'il était la personne la plus gentille
et la plus généreuse qu'elle ait connue.
Elle lui rendait visite là-bas, il lui a montré son CV
et elle a été stupéfaite.
Elle se disait : « Quand mon petit frère est devenu un jeune homme si accompli ? »
Après quelques semaines la visite de Suzanne à son frère et son épouse,
leur voisin,
Craig Stephen Hicks,
les a tués,
ainsi que Razan, la sœur de Yusor, qui leur rendait visite pour l'après-midi,
dans leur appartement,
en mode exécution,
après avoir posté un commentaire antimusulman sur sa page Facebook.
Il a tiré 8 fois sur Deah.
Donc, le fanatisme est non seulement immoral mais il peut même être mortel.
Revenons à mon histoire, qu'est-il arrivé après le 11 septembre ?
Avons-nous choisi d'aller à la mosquée ou la sécurité de la maison ?
Eh bien, nous avons parlé,
ça peut sembler être une petite décision mais pour nous,
il s'agissait de savoir quelle Amérique nous voulions laisser à nos enfants :
celle qui pourrait nous contrôler par la peur
ou celle où nous pratiquerions notre religion librement.
On a donc décidé d'aller à la mosquée.
On a mis mon fils dans son siège auto
et conduit en profond silence, vers la mosquée.
Je l'ai pris, ai enlevé mes chaussures, suis entrée dans la salle de la prière
et ce que je vis m'a laissée sans voix.
La salle était bondée.
L'imam a fait une annonce,
il a remercié et souhaité la bienvenue à nos invités,
car la moitié de la congrégation
étaient des chrétiens, juifs, bouddhistes et athées,
des gens avec et sans croyance,
qui n'étaient pas venus nous attaquer mais nous soutenir.
(Applaudissements)
A ce moment-là, j'ai eu les larmes aux yeux.
Ces gens étaient là car ils avaient choisi le courage et la compassion
au lieu de la panique et du préjugé.
Que choisirez-vous ?
Que choisirez-vous dans cette époque de peur et de fanatisme ?
Allez-vous choisir la sécurité ?
Ou allez-vous rejoindre ceux qui disent
que nous sommes mieux que cela ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Merci beaucoup.
Helen Walters : Dalia, il semble que vous ayez touché une corde sensible.
Mais je me demande,
que répondriez-vous à ceux qui disent
qu'être une conférencière de TED, quelqu'un qui réfléchit beaucoup,
travaillant avec un groupe de réflexion réputé,
fait de vous une exception à la règle.
Que diriez-vous à ces gens ?
Dalia : Je dirais : ne soyez pas éblouis par la scène,
je suis très ordinaire.
Je ne suis pas une exception.
Mon histoire n'est pas inhabituelle.
Je suis aussi normale que possible.
Quand vous regardez les musulmans à travers le monde -- et je l'ai fait,
j'ai réalisé la plus grande étude jamais faite sur les musulmans autour du monde --
ils veulent des choses simples :
la prospérité de leur famille,
du travail
et vivre en paix.
Donc, je ne suis en aucun cas une exception.
Si vous rencontrez des gens qui ont l'air d'être une exception,
cela signifie souvent que la règle n'est pas correcte
et non qu'ils sont une exception.
HW : Merci beaucoup. Dalia Mogahed.
(Applaudissements)